um we are back and i'm here with my new
pal edgar ramirez give it up
all right we are standing at our leg
turn of integrity
we don't pay jesse enough in honor of
edgar's new movie
are you pushing it edgar yeah i'm
pushing it and he's getting
amped up for the game um in honor of
edgar's new movie jungle cruz it's time
to play a new game called jungle clues
here's how it works edgar and i will
take turns giving each other clues about
animals found in the jungle
we cannot use words only motions and
animal
sounds which should be funny um if we
can correctly guess eight animals in two
rounds
the audience wins a fabulous prize we're
trying not to let you down just so you
know
for you yes this is for you this is for
you so i'm get i'm guessing first and
you're giving clues okay
i'm giving clues okay are you ready
because hey we can pass if you don't
know what it is you just say pass
okay okay yeah you're fidgeting too bad
you don't have any paper
yeah all right cool and go walk
walk a frog
uh hippo oh
yeah yes a giraffe
are they in a jungle okay a lizard oh a
a dragon are those the komodo dragon or
a lizard
okay okay okay is it coming i hope i'm
as good as you did good i'm sorry i
failed you on the last one okay that
means we need four more for the audience
to win yeah ready and go
um uh snake yes okay okay um
oh uh hyena yeah sorry it was horrible
oh yeah oh
uh uh uh uh slaw yes okay um
um can you see me
uh what um
i don't know what they sound like call
[Applause]
i love that i don't know what a flamingo
sounds like no well you did but you need
the legs
um we did it that means everyone in our
house eats wins as well you're welcome
so with hydro jug get all the water you
need in the jungle y'all the gym or
anywhere else you go
it holds 73 ounces of water and the
leopard sleeve slips right over the
bottle to keep it cold you're welcome
sleeves come in all sorts of colors and
patterns along with a shoulder strap and
pockets
you're all getting a 200 hydro jug gift
card
all right thank you so much for playing
oh please everybody catch
jungle cruise it releases july 30th
you're gonna love it yup i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever